All images should have an alt attribute.
Important images should
have descriptive alt text
that just describes what the image is.
Decorative images like here
should have blank alt text.
The screen reader will skip
that element completely.
You want to include blank text because
if you don't the screen reader may try
to read the filename and if the file
names weird, it'll sound weird.
So let's go through each of these.
The site logo, just gets and
all text of the site name.
The fact that it's an image makes
the fact that it's a logo obvious.
And even if it's a link to the homepage,
that information is implicit for
sighted users.
So there's no need to spell it out for
assistive technology users.
The shopping cart and the top right
hand corner, is significant so
it needs a useful alt text.
But the shopping cart in the Add to
Cart button is purely decoration.
So that can have an all
text to avoid repetition.
The main image here is significant.
So we can give that a descriptive alt
text and finally the thumbnail images
on the links to other dishes are also
decorative since the link text
provides the exact same information
we would have put in the alt text.